what is an can you tell me that
[Music]
what is that
what is
how do I know if if I'm a soul I
that's a great question
so we'll uh go through some of these
questions
today we'll start from Austin it says my
girlfriend I have two kids together an
infant and a three-year-old you're not
married I've worked at the same place
for four years and she got a job a few
months back I don't mind if she works
but the kids cry for her every night
that she's gone and they won't sleep
until she gets off at 4am I've run down
the checklist and they will not sleep
until mom gets home I asked if she
cannot work now so you've asked if she
can stop working and I can work extra
until the kids are a bit older in our
living situations a bit more stable but
she claims that even though it's
difficult for the kids and I when she's
gone at work it's not fair that I get to
leave to go to work all the time and
she's stuck at home with the kids 24 7.
I told her life isn't fair and life will
be more difficult if we just do
everything on a basis of fairness am I
the a-hole
yes but but not for the reasons you
might think uh I mean first of all life
isn't fair like that statement in an
argument
is
rarely going to have
you know a positive response you're
rarely going to get a productive or
positive response when you use the
phrase life isn't yeah well life isn't
fair it's true though I mean it's it is
true that life is is like fundamentally
not fair life is unfair and so you
cannot be obsessed with fairness all the
time so it's a it's uh it's you're not
wrong in the point but when you're when
you're having this discussion
um with your girlfriend but my issue is
just that it's with so you have this
conversation with your girlfriend so if
you're an a-hole in this situation for
any reason it's that uh like why why are
you two married yet man and what's
you have you have kids
you and your girlfriend have a
three-year-old and you're expanding the
family
and now you have an infant
um you you will you are tied with each
other already for life because you you
have a kid you have two kids together
you have a family
um and yet you're not married so put the
damn ring on and take us down to the
core to me that's that's what I uh zero
in on with this is that you got to get
married and but but it's relevant to
your question too because if you're
married
and you've both made that commitment to
each other then I think you've got a
much stronger argument you can make that
you could present to who would now be
your wife and say listen uh how about
for at least right now you don't need to
work you're working overnights you're
doing all this let me take care of you
okay let me take care of my of of the
family and we just had a baby the baby's
an infant baby needs you here like you
could I think that's a you can make a
stronger argument for that if you guys
are married but you're not the argument
is weaker and uh and without that
commitment she's probably also thinking
like if you're not married then the exit
is always just like right there you know
you could walk out at any time
um and so maybe she's thinking well I
gotta I gotta maintain a certain level
of financial Independence because we're
not married
um and I don't know this thing could
fall apart at any time men are the
coolest but I don't need them to survive
you do actually need men to survive get
married first
then uh Circle back
from Matthew says hey Matt am I the
a-hole in this situation I blocked a
friend who's also an SBG member you
better have a good reason for that on my
phone because on two separate occasions
recently he was rubbing in that my
favorite sports team lost and I was not
in the mood for it since I had a funeral
for my grandfather and he was aware of
that wait hang on a second so you were
at the funeral of your grandfather
and you're getting texts from your
friend making fun of you because your
team lost the hand you are one pathetic
loser is that what happened
um
okay in my prior interactions with him
he crosses the line from friendly banter
to being obsessed with the Rivalry and
making the school he roots for
personality trait even though he didn't
even attend the school I also wanted to
know your opinion on people like him who
are obnoxious about college sports
rivalries when they didn't even attend
the college they support well the not
attending the college thing that that to
me doesn't really make a difference you
don't have to have a direct tie to the
team in that way to root for the team
you know I'm a big Baltimore sports fans
I'm a fan of uh of you know the
Baltimore Ravens yeah that's I was never
on the team like I never had any any
official uh involvement with the team
but I still consider them my team and
when I talk about them to someone else I
use the word like we and us we played
real upwardly out there on Sunday like
that kind of thing even though I'm not I
mean I am in no way a part of the team
so I don't think that's the problem the
problem is what you said about making
your fandom your entire personality
and when someone does that you know yeah
it's going to be hard to have any kind
of real friendship with them I mean
blocking their number on your phone is a
pretty drastic step but it's going to be
hard to be friends with someone when
that's the only thing you can relate on
that's their whole personality sorry I
annoyed you with my friendship
and this is where I think some people
you know I bring up adults who are
obsessed with video games yeah you want
a piece of this you dude adults who
are obsessed with superheroes adults who
are obsessed with like going to Disney
World silly adult Disney for kids and
anytime I bring that any of those things
up and I say that the the adults are
obsessed with these things you'd grow up
a little bit I always hear well what
about sports fans you know that's a game
that's it's the same kind of thing
there's nothing wrong with being a fan
of a sports team but if that's your
entire identity
you know if you if you're if you get way
too wrapped up in it where it's the most
important thing in your life
um and you're giving and you're you're
giving exorbitant amounts of time and
energy to it well that's when it becomes
a problem and that's when you need to
recalibrate I would say the one year
anniversary of Roe versus Wade being
overturned is coming up and since then
the left has absolutely lost their minds
pro-life efforts which are more
important now than ever are booming uh
you heard that right despite the
narrative pro-lifers uh actually are not
going away they have increased in number
four days for life is changing hearts
and Minds in the most blue pro-abortion
states in the country they've had a
record number of locations since Roe was
overturned they grew in both volunteers
and locations with about 1 million
Volunteers in 1500 cities they hold
peaceful visuals outside abortion
facilities this success has come with
new unwanted attention as you'd imagine
from the federal government and the doj
in regards to free speech as one of the
largest pro-life organizations in the
world no one is in a better position
than 40 Days for life to end abortion in
each state in a post role America you
can help them fight the ongoing legal
battles of protecting free speech for
their volunteers including Mark the 40
Days for Life volunteer who had his
rated by the the FBI help them defend
free speech by giving a tax deductible
gift of any amount at 40daysforlife.com
that's 40daysforlife.com
all right
from SBG wife says looking for your
valued opinion on whether or not I am
the a-hole for refusing to name my
hypothetical future son after my husband
for context my husband and I recently
got married and planned to start a
family within the next two years my
husband was the only son in his family
and was named after his father
same first and different middle but he
is not a junior or the second I hate
that in all conversations with his mom
and family I never know which of the two
they're referring to oh sorry sorry
Peter Peter
God willing we both like to have two to
four kids and love to play around with
the baby name ideas from the get-go I
told him that if we have a son we will
not be giving him the same name as my
husband it's confusing and to put it
nicely a name I have I never have cared
for which is a point that I leave out of
the conversation wisely so as it at
first my husband was either
understanding or indifferent about it
now he's growing more and more insistent
on our firstborn son having his name if
my husband was formerly the second or
suffix Junior I would begrudgingly
oblige for the sake of continuing the
tradition something that his parents
didn't care to initiate and my husband
doesn't find important either I know
this is all hypothetical but am I the
a-hole for refusing to name our future
son after my husband and his father
I am also a believer that the woman
carries the baby and all should have a
majority rule over the name selection
I'm willing to compromise and either
have his name be our child's middle name
or if given his name as first refer to
our son by his middle name only neither
of which my husband is fond of Let Your
Sweet Daddy advice down okay
um yeah you are the a-hole actually on
this one Stanley you call your friend
and ask this instant
I gotta give you the yeah I got to give
you the title of a-hole on this one
um two reasons one is that yeah I do
believe that this is something this is
important to your husband
and uh and he feels
called to
have his firstborn son be named after
him to carry on and even even if you
don't put junior or the second or
something after it uh it still is
carrying on the name and carrying on the
tradition for our first son my wife is
the one who suggested it so maybe you
could be a junior and I shot it down
because it's just not something you know
I didn't I didn't I didn't want to give
my kid a the junior yeah they want to
make him a junior don't call me Junior
but for some man that's important to
them and um and I I think that you
should you should respect that and then
secondly
the woman has majority rule over the
name selection uh no
that's dumb you're dumb no no that's not
the way that works uh you
you are equal participants in creating
the baby
um you're both going to be equal
participants in raising and caring for
the baby in in different ways you know
the your husband playing the role of
Father are you playing the role of
mother but you're still both uh
intricately involved
um and indispensably involved you were
doing okay until you got to the last
paragraph and you claimed that the woman
should have the final say on names
um
that's that's not the way it should go
and I think
here's the way that with my wife we
never came up with like an exact system
for coming up with names we just sort of
with with each new kid we try to think
of a name and uh we have different
strategies that we utilized
but on a few of the occasions you know
because like we have a million kids gone
through this a bunch of times and there
have been a few occasions where my wife
just felt really strongly about a
certain name and uh and I said well you
feel that strongly about it let's go
with that and there are other times I
felt strongly about a certain name so
I think if one member in in the couple
feels really strong like I really want
this name
and you don't have those same strong
feelings for a different name then I
would defer to him okay
you a home
[Music]